- The first album you
bought was Britney Spears.
Is that true?
- Yes.
(audience cheers)
- Which one?
- 'Baby One More Time-'
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- Was the very first CD like, of mine.
That I owned, that was
like, very much mine.
And I ended up working
with her, which is crazy.
Crazy.
(audience cheers)
- What did y'all work on together?
- So I was, I was a
feature on one of her songs
on her album. It was
called "Slumber Party."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- [Tinashe] I'm telling you it was-
- [Kelly] Look at you smile-
- [Tinashe] Cause I was like in, in heaven
it still feels really
surreal just to be able to
work with somebody that
you know, you've idolized
your entire life was
was really, really, really crazy.
Still to this day, I'm like,
'I can't believe that happened.'
- She's super sweet too.
- She's so sweet.
- So kind.
- She's so nice to meet her in real life.
- I know it's always
nice when you see someone
that's blown up so big
but they're still like,
very like humble and sweet in person.
- Yeah. Totally authentic.
Like she's Britney 100%.
And to see her star
power on stage as well.
Like, when you're actually
on the stage with her
like filming a music video
with her, the camera's rolling.
- Do you feel it?
- You just see like, that character
come outta her and you're like,
'oh wow. That's Britney Spears.'
(laughs)
- But like, you're that
person now too though.
- [Tinashe] Well you know-
(audience cheers)